没有啊，
就今时今日，
你需要做的是选了一头就不要犹豫，
往前走，
如果你今天跟我说权衡利弊了之后，
你觉得男方带着孩子更好，
对你对男方来说都更好，
我也尊重你，
但是你选了一头就不要再回头，
不要再纠结，
就是往前走。
我跟我老公呢，
是在我毕业了之后去上海上班认识的，
我们两个都是当时是在一个公司，
我们做朋友的时候，
他带我去他家吃了一次饭，
觉得他的亲戚还挺好的，
我当时误认为那个是我婆婆，
他后面也表现出来他想追我，
过了两三个月就在一起了，
谈恋爱谈了三四年吧，
今天也会吵架呀什么的，
每次都是他亲自在中间安抚我，
就是宽慰我的话，
教我一些处理方式。
现在弄的时间久了，
模式就变成嗯，
有什么事情就是我跟这个亲戚沟通，
她再去跟我婆婆和我丽象去做沟通，
她是上了两三年的班，
后面就一直待在家里面，
不怎么去找工作，
有的时候找了之后一两个月就又被开了，
开了之后呢，
他就会钻一些漏洞，
类似于试用期拿一个月的赔偿嘛，
这种断断续续的，
我当时就觉得这个事情不太好，
再加上他一直也没怎么去上班嘛，
闹的这个矛盾的次数就越来越多，
那一年初的时候，
就是有一点犹豫要不要分开的时候，
结果那个。
之后我就意外怀孕了，
怀孕了之后，
后面又担心说小孩跟户口问题，
我们就结了婚，
领证，
然婚礼他们家是给了20个，
还有就是大概的情况是这样子，
在一起之后因为几个原因要分开，
第一个原因就是因为他前面那个工作的事情不怎么稳定，
然后第二个我再从怀孕开始，
他就不怎么管我，
也不怎么管小孩，
就是没怎么关心过我，
之间她还去聊骚啊，
包括生完之后还有发现他跟别的女的聊骚，
没有去酒店这种我不知道，
发现了之后，
然后也认了个错之类的，
但是这个事情我就一直很跟人于管，
小孩生了三年那出上都不怎么管，
也不怎么问。
第二个原因就是当时我们结婚的时候，
除了给20个，
还说给我们上海边上郊区的一个小房子，
大概100个的那个给我们做婚房，
结果在我生完孩子之后呢，
他家里面的人就把那个房子先卖掉，
当时就是来问我，
我说我不同意，
但是他们也就是通知了我一下，
就还是正常就卖掉了，
卖掉了之后说是去香港再给我们置办一个，
结果香港那个房子置办的也是他妹妹的名字，
所以是因为这个事情，
我对他的家里面的人也有一点就是不是很高兴，
第三个最后觉得就是闹到非要分开的时候，
是因为孩子三岁之前，
他都没怎么管我婆婆他们说愿意让我和。
我爸妈帮我们在老家这边带小孩嘛，
我是在上海，
就是生完孩子之后就辞职就回老家了，
然后我就在这边找了个工作，
我跟我婆婆他们都商量了，
他们也同意，
结果在小孩3岁的时候呢，
是突然跑过来说要把小孩带走，
用了很强制的方式去踹我爸妈的门啊，
就闹得要报警啊什么的，
就因为这个事情我觉得就没有办法跟他再相处下去了，
但是现在的问题就是小三岁之前都是我们在带嘛，
下去之后突然他就带走了，
刚开始去看了一下，
他就中间想办法去阻挠我了，
吵架，
然后就报警不让看了，
带小孩带过去也一年多了，
就大概是这个情况，
那你现在想要问我的问题是什么呢？
我的问题就是今年年初的时候已经申请了一次分开，
上个月判的结果是没判，
我就在想接下来下一步要不要继续打代表小孩的这样劝，
那你离开孩子这一年你自己是怎么过的呢？
你觉得你能适应吗？
刚开始的时候肯定是舍不得找办法去联系，
刚开始的时候他就会各种类似于要给小孩开视频，
就要听他的，
要按照他的时间来去上捍看他们的时候也是，
就是我早上8点多已经到上海了，
非要等到他们自然睡醒，
睡到11点才让看，
中间不让我跟小孩单独相处，
也不让给小孩过夜，
怕我把小孩带走。
因为这个场家他就报好警，
是我打他，
你没有正面回答我的问题，
在我的理解里面，
如果孩子都被我带回娘家了，
都被我养到3岁了，
谁敢过来跟我抢孩子的话，
我感觉我能跟他拼命，
他怎么可能从我手上把孩子抢走？
他就表现出来缓和的语气，
就是说他认识到他错了，
他愿意把小孩带回去，
让小孩去上国际学校呀什么的，
会给小孩更好的教育，
也会定期送回来让我们看，
你们都做的非趁好，
我就觉得如果去上海或者去香港，
那边确实能比小孩更好的教育，
他也说了这些能做到，
当时也是觉得可能这样会比小孩更好一点，
就让他带过去，
结果带了之后就看见了，
那你现在自己谈恋爱了吗？
没有，
还没有分开呢，
你现在今天想要问我的问题是什么，
我的性格里面有一点犹豫不决，
这事情很胆小，
这种他就是说他那边已经请了律师，
怎么跟他继续走流程，
他都会打赢，
然后把小孩拿走，
我就有一点点很忐忑，
说到底要不要去再纠结这个要小孩的这个事情，
因为我家里面的人他们就会劝认我，
说他这种性格，
你就算把小孩拿回来了，
他也会继续纠缠的，
或者你可能就拿不回来，
这是你自己的人生决定啊，
我只能尊重你的人生定，
我只能告诉你，
以你现在的状态，
你想要生孩子的抚养权是很难的。
因为孩子已经在他们手里了，
已经在他那里生活了一年了，
你现在想要说我打官司，
孩子抚养权归我这件事儿，
希望是比较小了，
因为当时他也不是说生把孩子抢走的，
也不是说他把孩子藏匿了，
你俩是有商有量的，
他把孩子接走了的，
接走这件事情并没有触犯什么法律，
也没有触犯什么规则，
至于他后来不让你看这件事情，
那你要保留所有的证据，
你去了他不让你看，
你得要留证据，
要有视频，
要有聊天记录，
要有报钩记录，
这个或许还能给你争取一点点空间，
因为他不让你看吗？
影响孩子的身心健康嘛，
损害你的对孩子的监护权吗？
你还有一点点空间，
但是这个空间不大，
比我的判断的话，
基本上现在孩子在谁那里过已经习惯了，
将来孩子就会判给谁，
我也在中间有在采集这个证据，
商量好的事情他都没有做到，
包括这个藏匿这个事情，
因为我当时第一次请律师的时候，
并没有去做那个倒钩的那个处理，
如果你想要孩子的抚养权的话，
你不是今天这个样子了，
你之所以拖到今天这个样子，
其实你的心里已经是放弃了，
你才会拖成今天这个样子，
我想告诉你的是，
既然你的心里已经放弃了，
就别纠结往前看，
如果你要真想要孩子抚养权的话，
怎么可能会拖到今时今日呢？
他把孩。
再走，
有一个星期你小孩子想的发疯了，
受不了了，
都得把孩子给要回来了，
去要了，
他没给被跑去上海找了，
他就躲在里面开门就骂我什么的，
他那的意思最好的话就是先把小孩带回来了，
这边稳定生活再去打官司，
可能判决我的这个效率会大一点。
是的，
你如果现在有本事把孩子接回来，
到娘家生活6年了之后再打官司的话，
你的概率又大一点，
你你自己比较好拿捏，
姑娘，
我们其实还是生活在一个丛林的社会，
这个社会就是穷不怕恨的，
恨不怕不要命的，
如果你连自己下的崽，
自己生的孩子你都豁不出去性命的话，
你指望谁能够帮你呢？
我话就说到这里，
家里面的人刚开始的时候你想要带回来的，
因为这个事情，
他们就说我放弃了，
让我自己后面好好过，
但其实我也觉得我这个性格就算到了后面也不一定会好好过，
姐妹啊，
就今时今日，
你需要做的是选了一头就不要犹豫，
往前走，
如果你今天跟我说权衡利弊了之后，
你觉得男方带着孩子更好，
对你对男方来说都更好，
我也尊重你，
但是你选了一头就不要再回头，
不要再纠结，
就是往前走，
我现在就是选不下来这个决定，
因为我觉得小孩在他那边，
他也跑出去上班，
都给他家里面的人带，
也不能陪，
教育的时候有很。
这地方你教育的不好什么，
那你还有什么问题要问我呢？
我就是想听听我一些最近的事情的看法，
因为人跟人的性格不一样，
如果这件事情发生在我的身上的话，
就我觉得谁来抢我的孩子的话，
今天得抢几个在这儿人跟人的性格不一样，
我说的是实话，
就是你身上没有这种杀气，
没有这种破釜沉舟，
没有这种谁来敢跟我抢，
我就能豁出去命的气质，
你也演不出来，
所以他们才欺负你，
被全家人才欺负你，
因为我这个工作他是体实内嘛，
也怕豁出去了之后工作什么的弄得不稳定了，
到时候也没有这个条件，
再把小孩弄成瞒，
就有一点软弱吧，
肯定不是说两个人有问题，
都是他一个人的问题，
我肯定是有我性格上面的一些问题，
你说你不知道怎么选，
这是你的人生大事，
要不要孩子这件事情你是不可能交给别人来给你做主的，
你只能尊重你自己的内心，
我就是每次被他激的，
就比如说他做了一些特别过分的事情，
不让我看，
或者理想着我一定要怎么怎么样，
但是这个事情如果你一段时间之后，
他做了什么事情，
你做这件事情的出发点是什么？
是因为他做了什么事情让你不顺心了，
所以你想要孩子吗？
他做了什么事情让你觉得激怒了你，
所以你要孩子吗？
这个出发点是错的，
你的出发点一定是我怎么做。
对于孩。
再说是最好的，
如果你自认为你不是一个很坚强的妈妈，
你自认为你也不可能给孩子更好的保护，
更多的陪伴，
更好的教育的话，
那你就放手，
我就是觉得如果我把小孩接过来，
我会好好上班陪育他的，
我觉得他在那边就是就在学校里面不管，
所以我就想姐帮我看一下，
我到底是在我这边可能会是教育更好一点，
还是在那边会生活的更好一点，
这个问题本身他就不成立的，
原因在于什么呢？
我没有见过你可以为了孩子拼出性命，
我没有见过你可以为孩子付出到什么程度，
我没有见过你在对待孩子的时候，
你在为他牺牲的时候可以做到什么程度，
我怎么能判断孩子跟着你还是跟着那边更好，
你当时就觉得他们家里的可以去香港上学呀什么的，
可能小孩在那边受到的教育会更好一点，
但是他自己又不是很争气，
都是他家里面的人，
就是很会，
我没有办法帮你做这个决定，
但是我今天跟你讲的话，
最值钱的那句话你一定要记住，
就是你选了一头就往前走，
不要回头，
我也理解你，
任何一个妈妈在做这个选择的时候都是要半条命的，
但你以后的路想要过得好的话，
你选一头就别回头，
别把自己折腾疯了，
好，
那就这样啊，
还有什么问题吗？
就是如果说我真的还是想要把小孩带回来。
的话就是还是要先带回来，
然后再去打班只是更好，
是的，
没错，
不是说2月份新出了一个禁令嘛，
然后按照申请禁令，
然后再收集证据的线下找一个律师，
一步一步指导你去做，
包括聊天记录，
包括打电话的录音，
包括干嘛的话都按照律师的指导去做。
对，
现在律师就是分为两派，
一派就是就这样去做，
做了之后去打官司，
然后打到什么样子去看结果。
还有一种就是我先想办法把小孩先带回来，
然后再打第机，
在选这个律师上面，
我也有一种，
我倾向于第二种就先把孩子带回来，
好，
那就这样啊，
谢拜拜，
推荐你们都去看电视剧战场上看一点这些剧的时候，
在现实生活中给自己一点勇气，
给自己一点什么勇气呢？
我连死都不怕，
谁跟我争孩子？
最后大家结局都一样，
当我能够为了我的孩子豁出去性命的时候，
我看谁来跟我争孩子，
那理解我的这个逻辑吧，
刚刚有个朋友说，
龙飞你别这样教他，
万一激出什么事儿来了啊，
我并没有教他说要怎么怎么样，
我只是说我个人的一种心境，
尤其是自己当了妈妈之后，
现在这种心境，
记得点赞关注哦。